I next have to invite myself up
give a brief chat about visual culture
calm
mutation in the digital humanities lab
and what we've been doing over the last
couple years almost everything I'm gonna
show today in my talk is actually a team
effort it involves user experience
design from Monica on read involves some
incredibly sophisticated programming
from Doug duhain from whom you'll hear
later it involves a lot of planning
organization advice and feedback from
Kathy DeRose from whom you'll also hear
later so I just want to preface that by
saying that what I'm going to show you
today is the result of a laboratory
coming together of trying to build
reusable tools for folks in the cultural
heritage space and so that's what I'm
gonna focused on today to focus on the
problem of visual culture computation
and I think if I do not miss remembering
I think this is actually a term that
Katherine Haskins is in the audience
today asked us to think about a my own
background as well as that of Doug and
Kathy and others in the lab is actually
really textual so we have degrees in
literature of some kind and coming to
Yale for all of us was this really
amazing experience because we started to
think about the world-class physical
Holdings that included oil paintings and
medieval manuscripts and sculptures and
things which will never be reducible
down to Unicode text so all the things I
had done on my postdoc of like text
mining Google books suddenly I'm in a
world where I've got RGB pixel values
I've got 3d data from sculptures and it
was really exciting challenge that
Katherine and others including our Dean
of humanities laid out for us in the lab
to be responsive to visual culture and
so what I'm going to show you today is
going to sort of be some steps towards
that what I'm really gonna try to focus
on is the problem of scale so the notion
of collection scale analysis collections
the gale experience is really important
to us and that's because I think all
none of us want to interfere with a
traditional art historical praxis of
sitting in front of an amazing oil
painting at YC ba or looking at archival
photographs that's how I was trained as
an undergraduate in art history that
will always go on what we're trying to
enable with visual culture computation
is methods and approaches which are
impossible once you reach the scale of
tens or hundreds of thousands of objects
and in order to start this conversation
I want to give my very basic attempt at
talking about some of the principles of
machine vision there's really no better
person in this room than me with a PhD
in Swedish literature to talk about
machine vision and deep convolutional
networks I can't tell you how much I'm
looking forward to this but what I want
to start is with the interactive thing
is if you have a cell phone if you
usually people say put away the cell
phone take out your Android take out
your iPhone and just go to your photo
library and doesn't matter if you use
Android or if you use Google photos if
you have photos on your phone doesn't
matter you'll either find a search box
at the top or at the bottom left
sometimes you have to pull down I'm just
gonna recommend that you type the word
cat cats are my favorite example for
this and in my example I have 254
pictures of cats these are generally my
sister's cat there's sometimes there
librarians cats here at Yale but so the
question you could ask is and you don't
have a cat you could try dog you could
try kid you could try car bicycle
whatever you think you might take
pictures of no matter if you use Google
photos if you're using it I've use iOS
you're gonna find what you're looking
for I hope and you could ask then what's
going on and why am I seeing pictures
that I have never labeled this isn't
Flickr
I haven't described these things I
haven't hired a processing archivist
from the by Nicki to expertly describe
this so who decided these were cats and
how did that happen and the answer of
course is that all of us on our phones
or in the cloud depending on how your
architecture is Google does it in the
cloud Apple does it on the phone there's
a convolutional neural network which is
captioning or describing everything you
take a picture of and this is really
powerful it means I don't have to go and
label my pictures in fact I don't even
think there is a way to label my
pictures on my cell phone right you just
take a picture and you can then search
for it so this is really powerful very
exciting and all of this although
theorized many years or even decades
previously really only hit the real
world around 2012 when a convolutional
neural network was able to solve a image
description challenge in a way that was
significantly better than other image
captioning algorithms in 2011 and so you
can see around 2012 that something
changed and it meant that we started
getting these systems which trained on
categories like cat and
dog and chair and bagel and banana would
be able to describe those things and so
this is what's running now in here in
all of our cell phones whether we want
it to or not so this is really exciting
why don't we take these systems which
can describe cats so effectively which
can find bagels and skateboards why
don't we take these machine vision
systems from companies like Google or
Amazon or Facebook and let them loose on
our cultural heritage there's truly
nothing that could go wrong here right
and so I just got back from a brief talk
in um Sydney in Australia and so I was
interested in this idea let's use
machine vision to catalog Australia's
sort of visual heritage so I went to a
Australian History Museum's of website
and I took an image the first one I saw
up and I put it through they're probably
the best machine vision API the Google
cloud vision API this is absolutely 100%
gonna give me the right answer so I gave
it the image and I said could you
describe what this is and it told me
that it was a fashion accessory um
probably jewelry with a little less
certainty possibly earrings but maybe
body jewelry or silver so let's actually
go to the source and figure out what
these are well these are leg manacles of
course from Australia's convict history
and actually the fact that Google would
recognize them as such is not something
that I invented it's something that our
curator in the Smithsonian told me based
on some experience you can only imagine
the the valence of this in an American
context with African American slavery so
what happened what went wrong well
really this isn't Google's fault and
this is not Amazon's fault it is has to
do with the kinds of usage and captions
that off-the-shelf captioning systems
optimized for they generally optimize
for the cats that I'm taking pictures of
or the cars or the bicycles on
contemporary images from 2019 um
images which are captured on cell phones
so we tend to take single pictures of
heute pets on our cell phones that's
what we use them for and crucially I
think monetizable use cases so it
wouldn't surprise me if Facebook has a
recognizer if I upload a picture of
myself drinking a coke they can probably
sell me an ad of Pepsi next time I log
in based on some brand recognition that
wouldn't surprise me at all the training
data and the categories make all the
difference and if there
bias it's in the training categories and
and the captions in the data not
necessarily inherently in the linear
algebra this sort of horrific
justification of a sort of a piece of
metal that is connected with a convict
or with a slave history depending on
which country you're in is not the only
unexpected juxtaposition of visual
culture and in fact artists like Fred
Wilson working many years ago in the
early 90s at the Baltimore County Museum
put together a terrific exhibition that
it was called mining the museum and
mining the museum is exactly what Yale
professor in American Studies and
women's gender and sexuality studies
Laura Wexler thought of when she saw
this juxtaposition of convict shackles
from Australia being described as
jewelry she thought of Fred Wilson's
installation within mining & easia
metalwork and so I want to acknowledge
Laura's point and I was actually able to
find an image of slave shackles here
were in the American context the unsub
in context at the bottom center of this
image juxtaposed by artist Fred Wilson
with some of the other elements of
material culture from Baltimore and
Maryland broadly the production of which
of course was enabled by slave labor
so as we encounter these sort of
unexpected or horrific Mis captions and
our convolutional neural networks it is
I think as we try to fix that worth
while thinking about what such
unexpected juxtapositions might trigger
in our own minds and I think that that
may be what Fred Wilson was doing in an
analog way back in the early 90s so as
we turn away from some brief notions of
of convolutional neural networks and how
they see and how they describe the world
I wanted to then move on to three
experiments with visual culture
computation that try to get around this
problem that try to use the power of
what industry can give us whether from
Amazon or Facebook or Google on take
these pre trained networks and in some
way shift them and distort them to serve
the needs of folks in cultural heritage
institutions perhaps in natural science
institutions what are the ways that we
can take the advancements that are
allowing me to find all the cats I've
ever taken pictures of but not
miscategorized the 19th century or
describe something in a way that's very
inappropriate so we're going to start
with the first one which is specifically
can these pre trained capturing networks
be useful without their cat
and in order to answer that question we
took a collection which is actually
split between the Yale and the of the
Yale by Niki Rare Book and Manuscript
library in the National Portrait Gallery
in the Smithsonian the majority of the
collection physically is in the by Niki
and then there's some very important
Matthew Brady negatives that are at the
National Portrait Gallery it's one of
the largest private collections of 19th
century photography from the 1860s to
the 1890s the Civil War the Gilded Age
and it's an incredibly rich and powerful
collection to look through it's famous
for its depictions of Lincoln there's a
problem though it doesn't include any
cats and as we know these calf and
convolutional networks are really only
good at finding cats so we have this
mismatch between our source data and the
networks which are really good at
describing the world and so the impetus
behind trying to fix that problem behind
trying to find a way that these networks
could still be useful but in a world
where they weren't trying to describe
things too explicitly is actually
unresolved in this demonstration here so
what I have here on the screen are just
a couple images from the Missouri Hart
collection there actually isn't too much
import in which ones are on the screen
right now this is a random sample from
our Civil War Collection um
what maybe is a little bit more
interesting is the ability to take this
website and do something with my mouse
so I'm going to move my mouse over this
dude here at the left and when I move on
mouse over him I'm gonna get images
which are visually similar to him and
when I move my mouse over this guy I'm
getting images which are visually
similar to that one move my mouse over a
guy in an oval I'm gonna get images also
in that same oval vignette let's go to
another image if anybody likes boats we
got some boats like houses we got houses
now in some cases these are actual
literal reprints and that's okay it's a
large collection reprints were made for
a long period of time in some cases we
know what these things are we have
captions and this happens to be
Lincoln's house in Springfield sometimes
we know who this person was we know it
in one image on the bottom right but not
in the top left um so those are reprints
but what I think is more interesting in
the then the reprints is the notion of
the pictorial conventions of depiction
here so what I can do by sort of surfing
surfing through this website is just
look at how people were depicted in
various ways based on visual similarity
and the visual similarity actually has a
lot to do with the convolutional
networks that we were talking about
before and this project is based on
pre-trained convolutional neural
networks which are designed to find
skateboards bagels and cats but in this
artificial vision system which starts
with very simple discoveries about maybe
lines or small shapes and evolves all
the way into this as a cat or this is a
dog we step back from that final layer
and we take the penultimate the semi
final layer in the network which gives
us about 2048 abstract dimensions of
sight there's really no way to describe
these 2048 ways of seeing except that
they are crucial in distinguishing cats
from skateboards in that sense it kind
of solves the future ization problem for
us we get a pre trained model we shifted
to do something else we have this
relatively high dimensional space 2048
ways of seeing so I think about one
dimension of X Y Z and then 2045 more
dimensions that I don't have letters for
we can do math in that high dimensional
space we can use an approximate nearest
neighbors algorithm to find the images
which are the closest to a given image
then I'm moving my mouse over in these
other dimensions and that's what results
in these all these other pages of
writing showing up perhaps because
there's one dimension which is
responding to a white background and
another dimension which was responding
to squiggles put those together you get
basically all the archival handwritten
documents in the collection so we are
basically taking pre-trained networks
but intercepting them and using them to
surface other images of women in sort of
interesting ways there's just this what
I think this tool really gives you is
the kind of way to surf through by
starting with one image and then sort of
discovering conventions of portraiture
in a time when exposure times were long
people took a good deal of time getting
dressed up sometimes their bodies were
even stabilized by metal stand so a lot
of thought went into these conventions
of depiction alright so that is neural
neighbors and my favorite example from
this particular data set which George
Miles helped bring to the by Niki is the
I call it the pugilists example so I've
moved my mouse over a boxer in the
bottom and I get all the other boxers
and what you'll notice here is that we
won intuition is that the network is
more responsive to line than it is to
tone that's one theory and this might
explain why it doesn't matter if
boxers facing left or right nor does it
matter if the boxer is Caucasian or
african-american now there may or may
not be an explicit category in the by
Nikki's own expert cataloguing of the
misery of Kuhn heart collection of
pugilist but it doesn't really matter
because we've sort of built a virtual
subject category on by relying on the
conventions of portraiture in this
particular collection
so that's neural neighbors and that is
open source software people can use in
fact we're pushing this tool forward to
help solve some problems that might be
familiar for those knew about the Pharos
collection of photography and we're also
pushing that in a couple different
directions we want to make this
available for anybody to use it's all
open science we didn't invent these
algorithms we just sort of put the put
it together and we also wanted to go
further and so the second technique I'm
going to talk to you about actually
builds on the idea of I have one image
and I want to see everything which is
similar to it in my collection using
that intuition of using pre trained
networks but stepping back from the
final category and going to a pre of
semi final layer which is more abstract
can we use that more abstract space as a
way of organizing the entire collection
on mass so this gets to what I was
talking about earlier with collection
scale analysis or collection scale
visualization and so we have another
software product out there called pick
spot and it actually uses some of the
same math that we just talked about pre
trained networks discard the layers
which are optimized for 20:19 take the
penultimate layer and then we have the
same dimensionality reduction problem we
need to somehow visualize 2048
dimensions in our web browser and that's
really tough to do with two-dimensional
screens so dimensional reduction is
basically like the idea of taking a
flower and pressing it between the
leaves of a book you as a human are able
to figure out how best can I crush this
flower and still preserve its
distinctive shape it's pretty easy for a
human to do that from three dimensions
to two dimensions to do it from 2048
dimensions down to two dimensions takes
more math and there are whole bunch of
techniques something as simple as
principal component analysis something
more advanced like T stochastic neighbor
embedding or tis knee and then a really
cool new algorithm called u map uniform
manifold approximation and projection
they're always a minimizing the loss
minimizing what you're destroying by
crushing that flower from three
dimensions to two dimensions and now we
have a two dimensional space if we're
successful in this reduction and we
somehow now have to show you a lot of
images all at the same time and so we've
got I'll show you how this works here
and for this demo I thought maybe with
the permission of annual to show some
images from the Yale Center for British
art so we've taken about 31,000 images
as we know the Yale Center for British
art is was a pioneer and putting non
copyright encumbered images online for
anybody to work with and so we benefit
from that generosity and I'm able to
take all of those images they gave me
and throw them on the floor but they
haven't landed randomly um they've
landed in such a way that images that
share the same visual characteristics
have landed on the floor at the same
place so I'm sure there's a technical
word for these I call them the
caricatures of dandies these are all the
well dressed men and very nice clothing
down here at the bottom left of my
visualization this visualization is in
fact the result of au Mac production of
2048 dimensions into two dimensions and
what I'm doing here is just showing this
reduction and hopefully you math has
been effective at keeping images that
look like each other near each other in
this much reduced dimension space
it isn't just these guys we also have
anybody here like animals let's go to
the zoo and here's the zoo and it's
everybody from horses to camels and
things like that on my screen there are
some other really interesting things
which show characteristics of ycb a data
all the vignette 'add fort of sketches
my favorite one maybe since we have some
natural scientists in the room is that
there's this really cool cluster of
botanical illustration I'm sure there's
a category for this in the explicit
metadata @yc BA I just think it's kind
of cool that this thing just all landed
in the same place and then finally um
there's some cool stuff down here the
Yale Center for British art of course
justifiably considers frames to the
artwork in and of themselves so we have
some really terrific frames here what I
love about this is these images of
frames are close to this other cluster
of images where the frame is too big
really in my opinion so it's frame ville
right we're in frame ville on but we
have this enormous visualization people
sometimes use metaphors of this looks
like a constellation um it looks like an
archipelago
Islands and things like that but this is
what anybody can do if you load your
pictures into pic slot we recommend at
least five to ten thousand images we are
pushing pics faut forward in some
interesting ways it is primarily offered
by Doug du Haim and so I do want to
acknowledge his work in programming this
in WebGL which is a way of programming
websites that's more akin to writing a
3d video game than using HTML tags
that's the reason we're able to get
really high performance out of this but
what I want to do is to talk about
another example from my own research I'm
going to give you about 30,000 pictures
from the southern Swedish city of lund
in Scandinavia and so we're gonna have
these images which were taken by two
photographers just to show you how this
works on on photography so we have these
unexpected clusters these are all sort
of from the early 20th century it turns
out people like taking pictures of kids
in chairs in the early 20th century in
Sweden these are all these kids and
chairs I had no idea this was a genre
and it's near by the cluster of standing
children so I guess as a parent you
could decide do I want my kids standing
up for their portrait or do I want them
in a chair um there's other examples
here turns out marriages go here pretty
well these are wedding pictures right
there's women in white gowns and there's
also something kind of cool I wanted to
show you which is we got build pictures
of buildings here in the center of mind
screen pictures of parks down here and
what's between buildings and parks turns
out to be buildings in parks so there
was originally probably one dimension
which was responding to the grass and
the trees and parks and there was
another dimension responding to the
linearity the roof lines the walls of
houses or buildings and you map a
dimensionality reduction algorithm was
able to somehow collapse these two lines
into a much smaller space that still
preserves this spectrum I want to show
you a really early alpha version of pics
plot which accomplishes something even
more exciting in this demo is going to
be showing you the interrelationship
between human metadata and what the
computer sees so of course when I was
dealing with the Yale Center for British
art images I was not taking an account
who painted that or who drew that on and
what we're doing with the new versions
of the pics pot is being able to pull in
these explicit metadata edges like
drew this who wrote this who painted it
what year was it and put that into
conversation with summer visualizations
so the first thing I'll show you um is
that we do have the ability to think
about these images in a variety of
dimensionality reductions this is just
the most banal this is just all the
images one by one by one that's pretty
cool but before we were showing you a
couple different dimensionality
reductions or now I can show you the
animation between them so we might have
for example these images which are about
30,000 orienting themselves into a tizzy
reduction which is just one way of
organizing them we can do that with
another dimension added in and you're
seeing about 30,000 objects move all at
the same time on your screen and WebGL
I'm tizzy has managed to orient these
down in a way that here's the
neighborhood of those kids and chairs so
we still have that clustering right each
algorithm will put the stuff in
different parts of your screen and
there's a stochastic or random aspect to
each visualization so we don't want to
take people to take these deterministic
we just want them to take them as
suggestive and in fact that's one of the
reasons we've moved towards this
animation engine so that people can see
that all of these arrangements are
really contingent and there are
different ways of thinking about the
data that are all legitimate this is you
map one of our more most exciting
visualizations because it certainly
clusters things in a certain way but I
think how I wanted to show you here was
this interrelationship between the
metadata who took this picture and the
algorithm which sees the notion of
children and chairs so what I can do
with this version of pix block is I can
say turn off a particular photographer
only show me pictures by Pat Baga or
only show me pictures by E - excellent
now when I do that most of the images of
children and chairs disappear there's
still this cluster of children's and
chairs but if I turn off pair Baga and
only show you
eita Ecklund then what I get is a much
reduced cluster whereas if I switched to
pair Baga here indeed are all the kids
in chairs and so what this tells you is
there's a substantial difference between
the job the output of these two
photographers who worked in the same
building and trained under the same
woman in Lund that their care and they
were active at the same time but this
woman did not shoot babies and chairs
that wasn't her bag she actually shot
I'm a lot of all images of all of women
in their 20s and 30s with very short
hair and in the American context
think of these people as flappers so
there's a separate cluster of flappers
that only eat epilim took pictures of
that's one of the things we can discover
when we put machine vision in
conversation with the explicit metadata
edges who took this picture and when did
they take it another exciting thing
about the future of pic spot is that we
want to turn this into a tool for
curators pretend we were going to that
zoo area we were looking at before and
you say hey I'm really interested in
horses so I'm gonna trust the algorithm
to cluster all the animals together
because it seems to do a pretty good job
of that
but I don't want any camels in my
collection because I'm preparing an
exhibit on horses and so what we can do
is let you have a kind of lasso remember
you're in Photoshop or paint and you're
trying to draw a complex shape around of
something so what will allow you to do
is to draw a your own circle or your own
lasso shape around just the horses that
you like you'll be able to shift select
deselect and then what do you do with
that stuff well you might download it as
a CSV file you might bounce it into a
PowerPoint you might upload it to a
makeup you might just have a kind of
list of things you need to take a closer
look at so being able to put the human
intuition into into a conversation with
a way that the Machine vision is
organizing these images we think is
really exciting we want to work with
human X piece not against it I think
that's my main takeaway I have five
minutes left and now I want to show you
something kind of edgy which is a little
around I think I like to think of this
as if you ever been working on a book
manuscript or an article or a student
evaluation and even working on this for
like every day this week your book or
your article or whatever maybe you're
reorganizing your closet it's all you
can do all day and when you go to bed
there's this horrible thing where you
start dreaming about the chapter you're
trying to write during the day it's like
it will not leave you and we were
thinking that we're making some of this
nvidia hardware and these convolutional
neural network software work really hard
all day we run these jobs for like seven
or eight days in a row and multiple GPUs
and the cube over there and we thought
well what's going on what happens when
these neural networks go off the shift
when it's 5:00 p.m. what do they dream
about like do they start sort of
hallucinating about all these portraits
they've been seeing during the day and
so what we wanted to do was explore the
notion
generative models and general for models
are of course a form of unsupervised
machine learning and the notion is that
given enough ground truth given enough
training data of things as they are in
the world algorithms might be able to
come to an understanding of the
probability distribution of the
characters in the words of a book or the
pixel values in a 19th century portrait
and we might be able to sample from
these networks and produce new objects
which have never existed in the world
before if you read in The Times or The
Washington Post articles about deep
fakes that's actually what's going on
here though generative models and so I'm
going to show you today a notion of
generative adversarial networks no the
cool thing about generative adversarial
networks this is actually two networks
working in tandem or more accurately
working adversarial into one another
generative adversarial networks consists
of two networks an art forger who has
shown images of tens of thousands of
objects and does its best to invent or
hallucinate new things there's a joke
here but then since selling the for
Jobbik to the Getty which I won't make
because we have somebody in the Getty
here
the detective though is working for the
art museum and he or she is looking at
all these objects and trying to discern
which one actually existed in the real
world and which ones were dreamt up by
the forger and what's interesting about
this rigid relation is that each of
these two neural networks pitted against
each other in an adversarial
relationship learns from its mistakes if
the forger does not get an image through
the detective then it says well I
screwed up and I got to do better let me
go back to the ground truth and try to
learn a better prior a better
probability distribution over RGB pixels
or characters if the detective
accidentally lets a fake Greek sculpture
through it then says I should never do
that again let me revisit my ideas about
what is real and what is fake and all
this happens tens of thousands of times
a second and we run these for days and
days and days so this is what happens
when we ran a generative adversarial
Network on the Missouri Owen Hart
collection on faces from this 19th
century civil war Gilded Age
action what you're seeing is the output
of the generator fighting against the
discriminator trying to arrive at some
kind of consensus on what a 19th century
face looks like and now some people when
they see this they think it is uncanny
some people think it's like a horror
movie or something but you're seeing in
real time the result of two neural
networks fighting each other over the
definition of a face it doesn't
understand what a face is but that's how
we interpret it as sort of humans you'll
sometimes see faces they're kind of
split in half I have another example
here I'll show you this is the same
algorithm run in those Swedish pictures
I showed you earlier and things are
about 30,000 faces and so you'll see
these two networks fighting each other
and you'll find there on the left if you
look on the right side of the screen I
have some samples drawn from the results
early on in the process what we call an
early epoch you'll see static I mean
this is no better than just random
pixels and that's because the generator
at the very beginning doesn't know what
it's doing it's like we'll have this
page of static and see if that works
and of course the discriminator although
not expert yet is good enough to
determine this is no good the middle
picture is actually I think an example
of a good example in the sense that this
woman never lived but if you looked at
this image of this face you might think
that's just a lossy JPEG base of a
Swedish woman not a problem and then on
the far right we have an example of
maybe overcompensation or some kind of
mistake the generator made which said I
got I got a face there with two eyes and
one nose let me try three eyes and two
noses and see if that works I hope to
god the discriminator realized that was
not a real human but you never know um
so what can we learn from these well not
much these are kind of really in the
realm of art but I think that it is
interesting to compare how algorithms
come to understand probability
distributions over RGB pixel values when
we ourselves spend so much time thinking
and looking at these same images looking
at the uncanny or the horrific is
sometimes a way of casting new light on
the work we do with the authentic and I
do think there is possibly some role
here for curators and other
professionals to work with these types
of things at least as ways of
understanding some of the aspects of the
possibilities of machine vision when it
goes off work and starts to dream
promising areas for the future
think that we do need to appropriate
algorithms from private industry I think
we need to build up expertise within
glam for machine vision I think private
industry partnerships are also really
crucial but I'd love for if Google came
knocking I'd love for people on Yale's
campus to bring all not only their
existing expertise but also some basic
knowledge of what these algorithms can
do I think Kline and combining
collections across institutions to
assemble for example reassembling
Meserve kun heart between MPG and by
Nicky I'm placing human curatorial and
disciplinary knowledge is equal partners
to machine vision we're starting to do
some baby steps towards that with being
able to show metadata facets in our
visualizations rearrange to suggest
multitude and complexity rather than
deterministic simplicity and let you go
in with that lasso and select things
that are meaningful to you and finally
and most crucially if you listen to one
thing I've said today it's that
institutions such as Yale and
Smithsonian are actually uniquely suited
to produce captioning models descriptive
models that do match the world of
bumblebees that do match the 1860's
because we have the excellent metadata
and we have the training data anomaly
metadata with the raster pixels of our
own collections rather than getting
upset that something is mischaracterized
an image we can retrain the last layer
in these networks and produce our own
19th century models of American visual
culture I think that's very promising so
with that let me end and I'm gonna else
we'll save questions for the lunch
[Music]
you